I'm starting today off a little bit
differently it's the last day of
February and this morning I was really
feeling really just kind of down about
the political situation and I know I've
said a bunch of times that I've sort of
become desensitized to the day-to-day of
what's going on stories that sort of
would pretty clearly be major scandals
at some prior point in American history
barely get any attention because it's
sort of scandal after embarrassment
after outrageous scandal day after day
after day and that's still true right
I'm still feeling desensitized to the
day to day but this morning I was really
sort of feeling like the futility of it
all I was thinking about the political
reality right Trump won he's president
he certainly not been able to do
everything he wants but he's doing major
damage to many American institutions
he's really embarrassing the United
States around the world and somehow look
I actually got to a place where I
allowed to creep into my head the idea
and maybe the hatreds whoo right in her
correct that maybe there's nothing more
to really do and the David Pakman show
should kind of like wrap up or come to
an end and I started thinking back you
know the show started when I was in
college sort of on a whim really and
it's grown and grown and it's gone from
something I did after class every other
Wednesday by myself to a five day a week
show with two full-time producers but
are we really having an impact right now
and on a day to day basis I laugh off
the hate reott mails I laugh off the
criticisms that are unhinged and
ridiculous and we have fun with it but
in some way I was wondering like are
they right are they right in some way
are we sort of trying to empty a pool
with a tea spoon sort of an analogy for
an exercise in futility and I've never
believed that it's a waste of time I've
never listened to the haters in a real
way if I had the show would have
probably ended in that basement in
Northampton Massachusetts
w XO J more than ten years ago without
ever having a single employee or dollar
of revenue and it's really easy to
convince oneself that you're having an
impact right like hey we built something
sustainable most independent shows like
this one never even make that single
dollar nevermind being able to have
staff and a private studio but what is
the political impact here right
maybe we failed in some way maybe I
should go back to electronic sales
although I couldn't cuz Circuit City is
out of business or a teaching college or
something and producer Pat can become I
don't know an airline pilot or something
and producer Noah Ferguson could go sell
insurance I don't know why I'm picking
these things but whatever right insert
some other activity and I realized I was
going down this negative path that
really served no purpose so I tried to
reframe and think about it in a
different way and I went back to our
audience email archives which are not
there only in case we ever need to
submit some of those emails as evidence
in a federal trial against someone who
sends us a hundred bizarre emails I also
keep them to be able to see the praise
that we've received then mixed in with
all of the hater messages there were
some really positive messages about how
I influenced this law school student
five years ago to go in the direction of
public defense or Environmental Law or
how that person two years ago had never
really understood why politics even
mattered but because of the show they
became not only regular viewers but also
activists for the progressive idea and
how I reframed at least in my head was
sort of to realize that it's really easy
to look around and feel like we can't
possibly be having an impact because
after all as I mentioned Trump is
president the u.s. is again becoming a
laughingstock around the world the
Florida Senate is putting together a
bill to arm teachers and we're
destroying our planet every single day
with our disregard for what's going on
with the climate
but then I realized I'm sort of ignoring
my own critical thinking which is that
it's really hard to measure negatives
it's really hard to measure the absence
of something and I wondered what would
we be dealing with right now worldwide
were it not for not just the David
Pakman show it's not a delusion of
grandeur but the whole of independent
progressive media and investigative
journalism and critical reporting that
have exposed political and corporate
wrongdoing and challenge the extremist
ideas in interviews and in analyses and
at least made attempts to create I guess
I'd say a more educated and engaged
public through pieces like for example
the critical thinking miniseries which
we're going to start releasing this week
and really it would be the worst
possible time to end the David Pakman
show even though this feeling of
futility I know is shared by at least
some of our audience it would actually
be the worst time so I know that there
are people in the audience that are
feeling hopeless and many are even
saying David he's gonna win re-election
I just don't know if I can stay involved
in politics I don't think I can do
another seven years of this I sort of
feel the same way on a day-to-day basis
but what I came to realize this morning
I was up early as some of you can
imagine how much time did I have to do
all this thinking what I came to realize
this morning is that we actually have to
stay involved now and for me that means
no no don't don't think about hanging it
up instead think about how to double
down and double the size of the show
which is much more difficult right it
would be way easier to say hey you know
what we lost the trumpets one they have
their guy they're spreading their brand
of sort of anti intellectualism and non
diplomacy and we lost and let's go be
insurance salespeople and airline pilots
and college professors or electronic
salesmen or whatever right but remember
Trump won because of seventy seven
thousand votes in three states
he lost the popular vote by three
million votes and he lost the world
which by and large
was on our side for the past eight years
and is by and large still not on Trump's
side as we've seen in poll after poll
after poll and the silver lining here is
that we do have a resurgence in
political activism as a result of this
administration the likes of which we
arguably haven't seen for a long time so
I actually I started in a very dark
place this morning but I'm here to tell
you that I'm recommitting to the growth
of the show not just the sort of slow
steady growth we've seen since Donald
Trump won in November of 2016 but I'm
thinking way bigger because it actually
is the time to grow not the time to walk
away and it's gonna require not only
doing the daily show that we do but
continuing to do the long-form pieces
doing the extras like the critical
thinking miniseries that starts to be
released this week but by the way thanks
to your support and a lot of other
things and if you believe that it's time
to renew the commitment you probably
think I'm gonna say become a member now
but I'm not gonna say that if I mean yes
sure if you value what we do become a
member but if you also think it's time
then help spread the message that there
are alternatives to this sort of
depraved anti intellectual pseudo
jingoistic nonsense that has been
perpetrated by those in the Oval Office
and whether it's emailing shows that you
listen to or watch and say hey maybe
interview David Pakman or emailing me
and say hey interview this other
progressive host or activist who's doing
something great or posting clips to
Facebook or even just tweeting and
emailing in and saying hey David I'm
glad you decided not to walk away
because what you're doing is valuable
and it's a piece of what we all should
be doing and that is doubling down now
and definitely not backing out so my
commitment here is that if there is the
desire and if there is the demand and
the audience infrastructure we're ready
to go sort of full steam ahead now if
the desire isn't there if I'm wrong here
and you're going to hear me say this and
you'll be more influenced by the idea of
walk
away rather than doubling down let me
know say you know what David I think
your initial instinct this morning very
early this morning was the right one
which is we've failed
we've lost there's no coming back and
you might as well walk away because
we're walking away let me know I don't
think that's the case I think I'm going
to hear from people who are going to say
no you know what David in spite of the
feeling of futility in spite of the
questions around what exactly was
accomplished over the last eight years
nine years leading up to Trump's
election if this is where we are now I
think the overwhelming majority in our
audience not the haters but really our
core audience is going to hear this and
they're going to say no no no it's time
to double down and we're here to help
you do that send me your thoughts I'm on
Twitter at D Pakman the show is on
twitter at david pakman show and we're
here we've got a fantastic program for
you today lots of news lots of activism
and lots of new things going on that I'm
going to talk to you right after the
break about